we've got a letter working up here can
you help me work out can you here we
work out what has taken this line to
this line what's been done to both sides
I think okay both sides move multiplied
by 20 I'll say it again both sides
multiplied by 20 you can see the 20 that
appears here 20 does it appear on the
left-hand side why is that what happens
on either side it has important
therefore move on you can see why did
the 20 over here because the 20 and the
4 will interact with each other leaving
you with five and that's what you can
see the top as we multiply by do your it
wrong advance of all time I fired okay
and the same thing happen to you right
the 20 and this 5 will in turn back
maybe do with four five six so 4 times 6
is 24 how long she said after
multiplying both sides by 20 she has
what what will be what's happening a few
things have shifted around wrap up this
one phrase that captures all of them
thank you she's collected like terms get
out of my class all of the A's are all
together the fives got over the other
side we added side to that side why is
that because we are trying to make a the
subject so you want to get a on its own
identifying true love for junkies who
agrees with this factorization yeah yeah
and you can see Laura and helpfully has
written down some to indicate the
significance of in 83 and product to
indicate the significance of the
negative 28 and sure enough negative 7
and positive 4th the digital one hand so
pull that off and those if you haven't
already you could write the questions
that we're going with
72 today and the heading is solving
quadratic equations right okay let's
transition straight into this now the to
review questions I've given you are
exactly the lead in to solving quadratic
equations because on the first line you
are solving solving an equation and this
question here's captain one that's a
quadratic right you've got something
that's square they're a little key go
now to make sure you understand what
some quadratic presence means we need to
go back to what solving B when you see
the word so that's all what was it could
you tell you what phrase could see
substitute if you didn't have the word
soul in the English language what could
you say said that would get to the same
place and survive I would not get you
there what what else could you say
what's that to offer you the value in
evaluate is an interesting word admire
things by the valuable but evaluate
what's like you can't evaluate in
equation you have to evaluate an
expression
what do you try to evaluate so as you
try to evaluate the printable that's one
thing you could do evaluate the produ
rule would be a reasonable city is
already filled so we could say let me
write the equation of the board would if
the equation you've seen familiar to you
agree on we're looking at perfect
squares see this equation here right
this equation is really special because
the matter what numbers you put inside
be you can make them one and five or
three 100 or negative pi in eight
million no matter what numbers you put
is this stable will be true but this
statement up here this equation is not
always true it's only true sometimes
it's only true when a is a particular
value and that's what salt actually
so babies find solutions but find
solutions but what our solutions
solutions are values for premium rules
like one a write values for pretty rules
you bat now whatever we want we want
this equation to be true right so they'd
make the equation true
some be equated not true you can write
equations but isn't true for example
businesses equation it's not true right
but we want to make this equation true
rather than this one our basic technical
way of saying that makes the equation
true because that's a bit colloquial if
we say that that is called satisfying
the equation satisfied without the
reason okay so let me just repeat it
right if you get nice and solved once
you try to find is a solution or many
solutions as the case may be what our
solutions
it's a equal something or x equals
something that satisfies the equation
takes at work okay yeah please know how
look a question to you just five minutes
ago you cannot solve this solve does it
make sense as a verb to go along with
this expression because it's not an
equation to just that but how do I know
it's not the question don't know equal
so it's not equal a 0 not equal five got
equal to a pineapples not equal to
anything dance so there's nothing that
can make that true right so therefore
you can't soul so doing back